okay so the whole town's frozen over
with black ice so i'm gonna have to wait
till that clears up to be able to get
back to the office so we're doing yet
another audio only episode of be culture
explain god i miss
i'm just showing my pretty face to you
guys
[Laughter]
john krasinski is supposed to be in
doctor strange too before we get into
that i do want to discuss something a
lot of people are asking if it's layla
miller in the moon night trailer for
those of you guys who don't know who
layla miller is
she's a she's a plot device character
and i'm not even joking like she 100 is
she has the power to just know how
things are supposed to be she was
literally writer brian michael bendis's
way of giving himself an out at the end
of house of m that's basically all it
was right i mean she is an unnecessary
character they killed her off i think
and if they didn't they probably should
have and it doesn't really matter
because she's been gone for years she
has no real relevance whatsoever my bet
is that in that trailer the layla that's
talking to mark spector is probably
leyla linsky the girl from the old
marvel presents comics back in the day
it was actually marvel presents number
54
where she originally showed up but she
was associated with like werewolves and
all that kind of stuff right so i don't
know if that's the case maybe they're
reworking her maybe it really is layla
miller and because she was so useless in
the comics the mcu is actually giving
her a purpose no clue anyway let's talk
about doctor strange too so uh a lot of
the rumors and leaks and stuff that are
that are coming out now the irony about
this is they've been around for a while
right um and the reality is that they're
gaining traction now one because of the
fact that the popularity and interest in
the movie is increasing those of you
guys who don't really know about this
kind of stuff is one of the cornerstones
of being a youtube content creator the
closer you get to a particular thing the
more excitement and interest drums up
for that thing so that's one of the
reasons why here on geek culture explain
and especially on comics explain we'll
kind of explore things a little bit at
the outset right when we're like a few
months out but the closer we get the
more content we produce about that thing
because there's a lot more interest than
there is if you're six months out from
there right so it's just kind of the
nature of being uh being a content
creator a little little peek behind the
curtain for you there um but one of the
big things that's been going on recently
and not even really recently is the idea
of john krasinski playing reed richards
now i'm not the first person to think of
this but i've been advocating for this
for years anybody who has been a part of
geek culture explain knows this goes all
this probably goes back maybe like four
years right then i've been like john
krasinski needs to play reed richards in
the fantastic four and and i think it's
kind of misplaced but a lot of the fans
that i have are like you're the reason
why everybody talks about the idea of
like john krasinski and emily blunt
playing reed richards and susan storm in
the marvel cinematic universe i'm not
gonna take credit for that i think it's
kind of arrogant to do so uh but i have
been advocating for that for a long long
time right they're already married right
they're exceedingly capable actors both
john krasinski and emily blunt have
demonstrated between john krasinski
doing what was it 13 hours that michael
bay movie and emily blunt doing um edge
of tomorrow that like they can do action
sequences right they could do like
action scenes where there's like
conflict and fighting and like
fast-paced stuff they can handle those
right because they have their marriage
dynamic we saw that play out in a quiet
place and they handled that perfectly
they're ridiculously versatile
actors and actresses right they're
exceedingly capable and so them playing
reed richards and susan storm in the mcu
just makes good sense well this is where
all the leaks are starting to come out
right like recently it was put on on
4chan which i never go to 4chan i
actually found it by way of reddit but
basically somebody posted on 4chan and
saying like screenshot this john
krazenski is going to play a variant of
reed richards from the fantastic four
and doctor strange 2. not only that
apparently ryan reynolds is going to
play a uh going to appear as deadpool
and like a post-credits scene now let's
talk about deadpool here for a second
right because this i think is probably
the more exciting thing here in
comparison to reed richards right reed
richards being in the in the in doctor
strange too that's cool and i'm really
hyped about it it makes perfect sense
and i'll talk about why it makes sense
for his character to be in doctor
strange too here in a minute but i think
deadpool is what people are really
really really really hyped about because
we all know that like marvel studios
owns deadpool now or at least disney
owns deadpool right once they bought
that entire section of fox and it was
only a matter of time before we saw him
appear in the mcu and i don't know about
you guys i'm really more excited to see
how deadpool would interact with the
cast of the mcu because they're a lot
more serious they're a lot more like
real world kind of like how people exist
here in the real world there are a lot
more like that and so when you take a
ridiculously comedic and over-the-top
character like deadpool and then you
introduce them to doctor strange i feel
like the pos the possibilities will just
be amazing
it would be hilarious right the only
thing that i wanted to see more than
that was the the goatee bros right the
beard bros those guys who don't know
what that means in in what is it all new
all different iron man by brian michael
bendis when marvel basically went into
the post-secret wars landscape there was
a moment where uh where doctor strange
and iron man had teamed up where iron
man had visited doctor strange or
something like that and because they
both had goatees iron man was like yeah
go t bros and like put his hand in the
air for a high five and doctor strange
just stood there with his arm across for
like three panels and then high fived
him right it was it was a little it was
a funny little thing right you know
doctor strange's goatee i'm surprised
they never commented on it in the marvel
cinematic universe which i feel like was
a missed opportunity but taking deadpool
who's ridiculously comedic and slowly
introducing him into these into the mcu
there's a lot that you can do there and
the funny thing about it is that
deadpool's post-credits scene does not
need to be overly complicated right like
if what they're looking to do is use the
post-credit scene as a way to segue his
character directly into the marvel
cinematic universe you can just do the
old christopher priest stuff right those
guys who don't know deadpool a lot of
you guys know deadpool is the guy who
breaks the fourth wall and addresses the
audience even if you're not familiar
with the comics you know that just by
virtue of word of mouth right it's just
one of the main state hallmarks of his
character joe kelly started that in his
run in the late 1990s but christopher
priest is the one who made it a mainstay
and when christopher priest initially
took over writing deadpool there was
this moment where the comment basically
opened with deadpool being escorted to
where he was going to quote unquote live
uh which was basically this trailer park
and like when he opens the door to his
trailer it's all the characters that
marvel had basically canceled because
back then christopher priest was the
writer where marvel sent the characters
to him if they wanted to cancel him he'd
write out the end of their story
sometimes he'd kill him off and that
would basically be it but deadpool
literally looked in the trailer and it
was just all the characters that
christopher priest had been assigned to
like end the runs for and he's like nope
not a chance so like he just leaves
and you could do something akin to that
in the marvel cinematic universe right
literally the post-credits scene is
deadpool like just kind of standing
there in front of a portal it's like i
wonder where this goes and then just
enters right and it's like he's in the
mcu now and that's it right it doesn't
have to be like overly complicated it
doesn't need to be super in-depth
doesn't have to have like a greater
meaning the post-credits scene doesn't
need to send us into a higher state of
entropy it can just be some basic simple
post-credit scene that fits in perfectly
with the comedic and nonsensical nature
of deadpool right like deadpool's in the
mcu because reasons and we won't care
right like we we really won't care how
it is that deadpool is over the mcu the
hand of god could come down and pick up
deadpool and sit him in the marvel
cinematic universe and we would just be
like cool deadpool's in the mcu now
awesome right i mean that that's that's
literally our that's that's how we would
react right it wouldn't really matter so
it is cool that we are apparently going
to see deadpool as a post-credit scene
in doctor strange 2 which is probably
going to begin the process of bringing
him into the mcu now as far as read goes
again it makes perfect sense that reed
richards would be in doctor strange too
one of the things that we've seen coming
out is that basically the illuminati is
going to exist in doctor strange 2
albeit in an alternate reality those of
you guys who are unfamiliar with that
we've had videos where we talked about
that specifically on comics explained we
deal with that heavily when we cover
jonathan hickman's avengers a new
avengers run but they're basically a
kind of secret organization right a
secret coming together of different
superheroes that basically just monitor
the various threats of the world that
exists out there i mean superheroes
probably isn't the best word they're the
leaders of various superhero teams right
so like name of the submariner black
bolt of the inhumans black panther uh
reed richards of the fantastic four
professor xavier of the x-men captain
america at one point in time iron man uh
you know dr strange these guys just all
kind of gather together and they operate
in secret just sort of controlling
things behind the scenes i mean it goes
about as bad as you would expect it to
be but one of the other things to kind
of keep in mind here is that whether a
lot of what's happening in doctor
strange 2 is a result of the the
aftermath of dr strange's spell or the
events of universes crashing into each
other because of loki it would make
sense that like dr strange is not the
only person out there who notices it
right that when you have the the kind of
return of the multiverse right this sort
of untwining of this rope as it were and
all these universes are just kind of
spiraling out of control and crossing
over with each other it makes perfect
sense that other people in other
universes would start to notice right
that maybe because somebody from an
alternate universe crosses over into
their alternate universe and they're
like what the hell's going on right and
they kind of start looking around and
poking around and then come to this
realization that basically the
multiverse as they understand it is
essentially going awry right it all kind
of leads back to king the conqueror but
the whole thing behind this is that when
it comes to reed richards one of the
biggest changes to his character came
during jonathan hickman's fantastic four
right i did an ama on twitter yesterday
and one of the questions people had is
what's the best run of the fantastic
four to read and my response immediately
was jonathan hickman's fantastic four
what he established there is that reed
richards has this obsession to solve the
problem of everything and that despite
what had gone on with regards to reed
richards exploring different universes
and things like that because of the fact
that it's not practical to like get into
a ship with the rest of the fantastic
four fly to the edge of known space
cross that barrier into an alternate
reality that what reed did is he created
something that was called the bridge it
was basically this giant kind of window
that allowed him to look into alternate
realities and so when you had the
collapse of the multiverse and jonathan
hickman's avengers new avengers one of
the things that reed richards and the
members of the illuminati did who were
really referred to as the new avengers
they used the bridge and they started
looking into alternate realities it was
really more of a task that was
undertaken by name of the submariner in
black panther but you started seeing
these alternate realities where people
were starting to realize something's
wrong with the multiverse some of them
did the exact same thing reed richards
did where they were looking into
alternate realities others were
blissfully unaware of what was taking
place but it makes sense that if anybody
out there in alternate realities is
going to start looking around and
realizing something's wrong with the
multiverse and start investigating on
their own it would be read and we would
have to believe that like if the
illuminati really does exist out there
in doctor strange too reed richards
would have to be a part of it and he
would be their science guy right the guy
they turned to for these questions
involving science right like tell us
what's happening he was part of the team
in the comics he'd be part of the team
in the mcu more so than that and
moreover it would also make sense that
this illuminati would be aware of kane
the conqueror right they would be aware
yes the multiverse is falling apart and
it's all because of that guy and what
we're basically trying to do is either
try to find a way to stop him or try to
find a way to keep our universe
protected right maybe isolating it or
something along those lines and someone
like doctor strange represents a
credible threat because if their
universe is hidden away or if they don't
exactly know that it's king and then
suddenly this multiversal magician
basically shows up in their in their
universe that it's like okay that guy
has to be part of the problem or
something like that right the encounter
between doctor strange and the
illuminati it's predicated on the idea
that the illuminati is still trying to
figure out what's going on and they
think it's steven strange right so reed
would certainly be a guy who would be a
part of that and it would be even more
interesting if that alternate reality
version of reed knew about the marvel
cinematic universe right like i've
watched everything unfold in your
universe or i just recently started
watching your universe and i saw what
you did for spider-man kudos to you uh
we still got to lock you up because we
don't really know what your deal is but
hey man like you know it was a cool
thing you did right something along
those lines again we don't fully know
what role he's going to play the only
thing that i would say i'm disappointed
about with the idea of krazynski playing
reed in this capacity it's probably the
same thing that a lot of you guys are
disappointed about which is it's
basically him playing an alternate
reality version of reed in truth maybe
this is a test right it may be one of
these test kind of things because
something i've been saying for quite
some time is that yes we're having this
kind of unraveling of this rope of
collected universes that all basically
led to the the the establishment of the
creation of he who remains right and
that any other alternate reality that
would lead to any other variant of he
who remains specifically came to conquer
was basically pruned right it just
wouldn't be allowed to reach its
conclusion so they would never have to
worry about kane coming into existence
but with that not being the case the
multiverse is just sort of spiraling out
of control that either this is going to
lead into secret wars or it's going to
lead into some kind of circumstance
where at the end of all this everything
is contained again right the genie is
quote unquote put back in the bottle
right the mess is cleaned up and what
it's going to lead to is the marvel
cinematic universe basically grabbing
all these different things that exist
out there right deadpool in the from the
fox properties x-men for the fox
properties the fantastic four from the
fox properties and just roping them all
in into a singular universe so the
multiverse will exist but basically it's
the the events between uh really
starting in loki going into spider-man
no way home going into doctor strange
two probably into ant-man quantum mania
is quite literally the marvel cinematic
universe just reaching into alternate
realities and grabbing these different
characters and consolidating them all
down so that when the day is saved kane
the conqueror is defeated and the
multiverse is returned to its normal
state that now in the marvel cinematic
universe you've got john krasinski reed
richards and you've got the cast of the
x-men whichever ones they want to keep
you've got deadpool you've got all these
guys out there who previously existed in
alternate realities but because their
universes were destroyed or because all
the different universes out there were
just condensed down into a singular
universe now they all exist in the same
place right i've been saying that for a
while so while i will say that it is
kind of disappointing to see john
krazenski playing like some alternate
reality version of reed richards and
that it's entirely possible that like
after doctor strange two we never see or
hear from him again the other side of
that coin is he's coming to the mcu it's
just waiting until the events of like
king the conqueror and the multiversal
calamity and chaos and everything all
just sort of corrects itself right where
it's all just fixed and then we will
have john krasinski fingers crossed
emily blunt as susan storm in the in the
marvel cinematic universe as the you
know the the reed and susan of the
fantastic four going forward forever i
don't care who they cast as anybody else
i would i would kind of love to see
michael chiklis return as the thing
right there wasn't very much that was
great about those original fantastic
four movies but michael chiklis was a
great ben grimm
where they could also bring back chris
evans to play johnny storm that would be
hilarious like hey guys it's me captain
america or at least i used to be now on
the human torch
just the benefits of just being awesome
like me i mean i think it'd be kind of
funny you know but regardless there's a
lot of possibilities here so let me know
what you guys think down in the comments
section right are you guys excited about
this news are you kind of like it's okay
whatever we'll just wait until we get
closer to the release date to find out
what's really going on or the movie or
what have you do you think the marvel
cinematic universe is pulling ruses
right like the doctor strange two
equivalent of andrew garfield right
denied deny deny and then he jumps
through a portal rips his mask off and
the top comes off the theater i mean
what do you guys really think is is
going on here let me know down in the
comments thank you all for watching and
i will catch you all later peace